man why don't they just go to a shelter
well they have to be on the streets oh
man the shelters the shelters good
questions at least okay so in Orlando
all the shelters are full and they have
been full for a while permanent
Supportive Housing is at capacity there
is no more permanent Supportive Housing
and rent has gone up for some people as
much as 600 700 800 a month where are
people gonna go
oh
welcome to LED live it's the show where
we use the Light of Christ to expose the
darkness found in media and our culture
today and you know we usually focus on
what's happening in Hollywood and what's
happening in the news sometimes we Zone
in on what's happening in our own
personal lives but today
we're going to talk about what might be
happening outside of our front doors in
our communities so I'm very excited to
have Eric will and Gerard as guests on
the show today
you guys are here almost two years ago
yeah yeah yeah yeah so we're happy to
have you back you're welcome
to the LED live table glad to be here
and so first time you're all part of a
Ministry called salt salt Outreach
Ministry so first tell us for those who
may not have seen that first episode
that we did about two years ago or those
who didn't need a refresher what is salt
why salt you know what kind of name is
that let's get into that yes so salt is
a uh is an acronym for service and love
together
um we operate a mo we call it mobile
drop-in center for people experiencing
homelessness normally cities will have
drop-in centers people watching might
have a drop-in center in their city
where someone experiencing homelessness
will go there they can get a shower they
can get laundry they can get case
management mail services haircuts all
that stuff is there in that building the
difference is we provide It On Wheels so
we have a shower trailer with four
bathrooms a laundry trailer with six
washers and dryers we do a hygiene
products clothing snacks we do haircuts
mail services charging stations for
devices we do limited storage Services
Case Management Mental Health counseling
and we do spiritual care and spiritual
care is what these two guys what their
role is they're our Outreach pastors so
they provide things like you know Global
Studies yeah group Bible studies
kind of building the relationships
um uh I think one of the biggest things
that we've come across is the fact that
we are like bridges for other services
at Salt yeah and so we tend to establish
like a relationship kind of like a
report with the people
um and next you know one day somebody
just be like hey man I'm tired of this
uh right I want to go into to rehab but
I want to say really right let's go man
I know the person to talk to you know
you know oh I was going to say just say
for context we're we're right now we're
serving over 100 people a day five days
a week in downtown Orlando on any given
day we have 400 people experiencing
homelessness into our campus
and uh it's it's every quarter fifty
percent of the people we see are new to
homelessness so it's it's 50 every
quarter it's we got some repeating but
then they're though some are new every
day we have one to 15 new people for
sure when you were here last time you
said there's you average around a 10 10
000 people in Central Florida who are
experiencing homelessness has that
number changed has an increased decrease
and then why what are the factors that
contributed to that yeah homelessness
has been increasing in Central Florida
um it's it's pretty significant
um so they did a study in 2020 and they
realized that every increase in median
rent by a hundred dollars increases
homelessness by nine percent in Florida
in the past couple years we've had a
median increase of 600 in the past two
two and a half years so now we're
looking at homelessness continuing to
increase we're seeing more single moms
families a lot of children
um younger people younger people people
you wouldn't you know you see out there
you're like you know it's just it's like
you're at the store and you just saw
someone you know it's like you never
know it could really happen to anybody
and we're seeing that now oh yeah
definitely so we're seeing some older
ones really big and crazy yeah older
older people we're just talking about
client that's 78 years old that's
getting services with us yeah older
women people in wheelchairs I mean you
name it pregnant one we had a pregnant
woman which she was pregnant with
triplets with triplets two twin girls
already four years old already sleeping
in her car that was one of our clients
right it's it's it's just mind-blowing
okay so there's a lot wrong with the
world today but why is this population
pulling on your heartstrings like what
got you specifically involved in this
ministry let's start with you Gerard
yeah I think for me
um
I was I don't know it's just in college
and I guess coming closer to Christ you
develop eyes for everyone
especially those who are on the lower
ends of the social stratum so you know
it was something that I had to do okay
you know but it was it was like how
could I not
um drive by somebody and see that they
were in need or see them on the street
or whatever like what can I do to help
them in some type of way so I think just
um drawing closer to Christ and him just
showing me what it looks like to see
people allowed me to see not just my
fellow brothers and sisters that I'm
connecting with but even those who are
like Shadows of society so I think
that's how it kind of um developed for
me back in the day like when salt
a long time ago when we kind of started
up and stuff like that and uh it just
kind of continued since then so you've
been there for a while how long yeah
yeah since the Inception yeah really
yeah okay yeah yeah that's great yes
um man well sorry I should ask when was
the Inception like what year I was in
2011 but I feel like things were brewing
a little before that but yeah you know
you could probably speak a little more
to that right yeah I was also in the
Inception around
um 2011 and
um yeah I think for me it was studying
more this word of God
um and realizing that it's really
shifted towards action
and how we treat people you know um and
I think one of the biggest things for me
was uh Matthew 25. you know um you know
when Jesus goes off on like his whole
teaching moment and he goes on a string
of Parables and stories to illustrate
the point of you know they're asking oh
like Jesus when will you come back he's
like that's not the question
right I am coming back you know the
question is how will I find you when I
come back you know and then he goes off
on these Parables showing like hey be
ready this is how you're ready this is
how you Vigilant but the last parable
is um man it's just something else when
you look at it because it's it's
prophetic right it's a prophetic Parable
so you're reading about yourself when
you're reading this Parable
um and he's just like
the question wasn't wasn't really like
how did you treat my law how did you
treat it it was just how did you treat
my people
that's what I'm looking at that's right
um and I was hungry I was naked I was in
the streets I was I was in prison I was
sick I was just I just how did you oh
you know well you did this to them you
did it to me you know and it's like well
when did we see you he's just like when
you saw somebody else like this that's
so true you know growing up my mom
always used to say this quote uh usually
in like a discipline type way but it
applies broadly yeah and she says
learning brings about a change in
behavior and so that is what the Bible
is there for it's not just for our
knowledge you know it's to put into
practice the things that we read in it
so that is amazing that you through
Bible study you're like hey I need to
put this into action and you got
involved and that's definitely a call
for all of us to do yeah what about you
Eric well you started the ministry so
yeah yeah started back in 2011
um September 2011
um it's been a journey uh before I was a
Christian I became a Christian in 2010
um and before that I had experienced
homelessness myself so I was a 19 years
old
um sleeping in my car in Chicago
trying to I was just being prideful and
being you know my head was in the right
place and uh I speak experienced it for
six months so like going to 7-Eleven and
trying to take a shower in the bathroom
there uh you know going to the Mexican
restaurants eating the the free chips
you get in the beginning and then
leaving
um if I had a dollar go to Panera Bread
get a piece of bread rip it in half get
a ton of butter and that would be my my
meal so I had to figure out how to how
to make it work
um but having experienced that and then
coming to Christ it just the pieces came
together
um and you know I I think also like man
like this group of people are some of
the most vulnerable people and most real
people that you you'll meet yeah you
know it's it's crazy there was a there
was a stat I read recently and I said
many people majority of people
experiencing homelessness go months
without hearing their name oh
and there were some people that have
that gone over a month without even
speaking one word that's wild could you
imagine living a life like that like
isolation isolation I saw a video on
social media of someone going around
giving haircuts to homeless people and
he did it to one man and the man started
crying uncontrollably and he's like oh
like did I nip you or something like
hurt you he's like no no I just haven't
been touched in years yeah wow and just
the the the the act of touching my
person yeah was so like a warmth that he
had hadn't felt in so long and I was
just really like taken aback by that
yeah how long of a period can pass
without the things that we take for
granted right yeah or even treatment I
remember one time we were doing um an
Outreach uh we actually went out to
Indianapolis and representing salt and
uh doing showers out there and uh we
were able to help someone go from the
shelter take them shower and all these
things like that
um and when I was dropping him off he
just turned to me
with like tears and he's just like thank
you for treating me like a human
and yeah that brought me to tears
because I'm like man like you are a
human that's what I told him I was like
you are you know so it's it's it's uh
servant yeah and the flip side to that
is is it really sheds a light on how
society looks on that group of people
and how they treat them and we're going
to get into some of the misconceptions
about
um homelessness and what goes into that
but you know there are many reasons why
people become homeless whether it's
natural disasters right or or as you
were talking about income or or or
addiction and these different things and
there are many factors that keep people
homeless lack of support system or their
mental health deteriorating and of
course there are steps that need to
happen before someone comes out of
homelessness and gets readjusted into
society yeah so does your ministry cover
all aspects of that or do you target a
specific area that involves homelessness
yeah no that's a good question so we we
are a comprehensive drop-in center so we
do have case man a case management team
and the way our case management works
it's very we've created it to be very
relational so it doesn't matter who you
are what caused your homelessness
whatever if you want your homelessness
to end our case managers will see you
they'll do a full needs assessment
they'll figure out all the needs that
this person has then they'll prioritize
those needs by turning them into steps
okay John here's the first step let's
get you over to this organization that
can help you with this after that come
back and see me we'll set an appointment
for this date he comes back all right
John great let's go on to the next step
because then they can clearly see at the
end of the tunnel hey this is how I can
get back into housing it brings that
hope back you know
um and so so it doesn't matter how
they're there could be addiction could
be mental illness it could be a loss of
job income you know the common
denominator we see with everyone we
serve is is is not any of those things
the common denominator is a lack of
support they don't have someone in their
Corner that is able to be that support
for them to believe in them to root for
them to to get to where
um you know to where to where uh they're
they're stable again and so salt
was created as a way to be that support
for these people um so they have someone
Rudy in their Corner yeah because it's
hard when you're by yourself I mean oh
yeah you know life's already hard yeah
it's already hard by yourself yeah right
right so you brought a video with you to
give a sort of visualize to everything
you just explained so let's take a look
at that now okay
taking a shower or doing a load of
laundry things that some of us can do
routinely without a thought but that is
not the case for everyone in our
community this week's community champion
is working to change that and change the
lives of those struggling with
homelessness sonicadange introduces us
to salt
how are you doing today all right Curtis
Hawkins is salt Outreach to
an organization that changed his life a
little more than a year ago what can I
help you with today I wanted to schedule
your apartment the non-profit
organization which stands for service
and love together launched at the end of
January 2021 its goal is to take the
homeless to homebound I was in my car I
was sleeping in
parking lot I was sleeping there
sleeping in the cellar parking lot I was
sleeping I just about everywhere Curtis
had heard about salt from a friend in a
similar situation the mobile day center
located on West Central Boulevard offers
mobile shower units laundry services
haircuts even mail service a lot of
people they need an address to be able
to progress you know to get their Social
Security checks their food stamp cards
their IDs and so this has been a key
piece in helping to end homelessness you
need socks Curtis is one of hundreds who
didn't just find a hot shower and food
when he arrived do you have your
transportation information there a case
manager helped transition his life back
under a roof they even linked him with
physical therapy I know how to talk more
better
I could walk more better
before I would have any problems
and
when I got on the phone
I talked to somebody
like I call an organ Edition I talked to
him
they leave or hang up
cause my streaks after about half a year
of Salt's help Curtis moved into his new
home in the summer of 2021. this is a
note we sent to Curtis after he moved
into his place framed on his wall a
letter from his friends congratulating
him on his success
having those relationships and being
able to call somebody by name and they
know that you care about them that is
key to Salt's success because the more a
client comes back to take a shower or do
laundry the more likely they are to sign
up for services like case management
which can lead to help finding housing
or Medical Services Salt survived for
much of the pandemic through local and
state grants and from donors across the
country but while the covet grants were
coming to an end High inflation and a
lack of affordable housing is driving
demand for services up and we'll call
you when we're ready okay that's why the
organization is so grateful for the
volunteers and donors who support their
cause I I just feel so grateful to be a
part of the journey that I see some of
our they're not just people who who are
experiencing homelessness they're truly
people that we built connections with
like I care about and I don't want to
see them in this situation and even
after the clients have been homed salt
continues to check in helping book
medical appointments when needed and
maintaining bonds that were forged for
life now you you've been housed for a
year
yeah yeah back for a year how has that
been it's been been great I can take a
shower when I want to okay just lay
around it was it was
it was his birthday it was the blessing
which thought gave me security
because sleeping in America we don't
really get down to sleep
because he's sleeping with one eye open
every little thing you hear you wake up
you see but both eyes closed now yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I wake up refreshed sonicadange WESH 2
news wow what a powerful testimony I'm
curious do you have any other stories to
share of your experience being out in
the field
man yeah I feel like we were just making
this we could yeah yeah for sure yeah
right I hope so that's in the works
right yeah yeah I think it's definitely
encouraging to see and to be a part of
like to see like the Journey of someone
um who comes getting services and you're
rooting for them you know and you're
trying to provide all these services and
and genuinely building a relationship
with them and then seeing them get a job
they're getting a job to like oh yo I
just gotta I got a a place and it's like
what you got a place like then like
finding people that are donating
furniture was like yo we got your
furniture and I'm taking the furniture
right right you know and then you're
talking to them and they're just like yo
I just gotta uh I just gotta like a
promotion emotion at my job to then
seeing it full circle them coming back
to Saul to volunteer so so you're
telling you you're you're you're the
story you're thinking about you're
thinking about Richie and when you're
thinking of the things
there's so many people but like with
with him I mean he was experiencing
homelessness for two years when we met
when we met him yeah and he came for you
know services like showers and laundry
and mail and he started to go the group
Bible studies and and from there he
ended up going to case management and
when he went to the case managers they
ended up helping them uh you know assist
him with getting a job he got a job then
a few months later he moved into his
place in January area of this was it
this year this year yeah January of this
year and then in February we got a text
um saying he got promoted at his job oh
yeah and then the next thing you know
he's volunteering with us yeah yeah and
he's speaking at a Gala that we did you
know what I'm saying like it's just it's
crazy it's crazy to see and and now all
of that happened from when you met him
to when he was promoted to in this new
job after being in housing it was
probably like eight months eight nine
months really yeah yeah beginning last
year yeah compared to like two years of
homelessness that's a pretty quick
turnaround yeah yeah wow I um was
thinking of somebody
um that recently came around and I
realized how important it is to be
um someone that someone can can burst
upon this is what I mean a lot of times
when some of our brothers and sisters
are experiencing homelessness they're
being filled with so much and they don't
have a place or space where they can
release this onto they need to kind of
break you know they've been holding
things in for a while so our one of our
brothers
um he recently came you know
situation children all of these
different types of things he almost got
killed like right before he ended up at
our at our site and he just started to
share his story share his story and he
just he just broke he just he just burst
like a balloon and he hadn't done that
in I don't know a while he hadn't shared
his story with anyone actually and just
just to see him be able to do that and
then be able to help him like get his ID
and things of that nature
um it was just an amazing thing because
it now he's he's free now you know he
doesn't have to hold this in anymore
here's someone who's safe who I can go
to and who I can share myself share the
deeper depths of why you see me because
sometimes we see a lot of people we
don't really know yeah what's their
experience I mean being in that extended
state of survival mode I'm not sure
exactly
yeah there's no time to pause and be
like man can I just
I just be human right now because I'm
just always looking around I'm always
looking around yeah I mean when you're
sleeping and you're waking up every 30
minutes a bug crawls on you a car passes
by with like you're trying to make sure
you're not stolen right yeah if you're a
woman it's even worse yeah yeah you know
um you're in a constant state of
survival you know so it does take a toll
psychologically right well let's get
into that the the reality of
homelessness
um what it looks like and why people
homeless people might react in a certain
way to people who aren't homeless that
may be the people who aren't homeless
don't have that perspective and so they
end up judging them instead of
understanding them yeah no definitely
man yeah there's something I want to
share is because like we think of like
oh the reason they're homeless or
someone's homeless because of this and
this like
we're literally just a few paychecks
away like you know something happened to
me like personally like I I you know
paying the utilities of where I stay
um and it's always like the same price
right it's like okay it's like 300 you
know I live in a house family you know
um and then one bill comes as like a
thousand three hundred wow and I'm like
wait wait wait something's up here like
and then we're like no something got to
be wrong and then we reach out to the
place and they're just like no you're
just in a zoning area where the price
went up oh I mean that's quite an up for
sure it's quite enough
yeah but it just shows me like man it's
difficult yeah how things could just
switch up and now I can't afford it
right you know and it may not be
anything that you did wrong it's just
right nothing something what that goes
to show is that homelessness doesn't
discriminate no it doesn't discriminate
um what you look like where you've come
from
um social you know income whatever it
just doesn't and I think that sometimes
those who are on the other side
um it's it's a little I guess scary for
them because maybe they've heard a story
oh this homeless person attack this
person or whatever the case and that's
all that they might know so it stops
them sometimes from from going into
those spaces availing themselves you
know to serve and to help yeah yeah
that's why it's important for us
um at Salt we don't call them homeless
right okay we call them homebound
exactly you know and it's just like
homelessness is not who they are it's
what they're experiencing gotcha right
you know and so like reminding them like
you know your homebound like you know
you're about to like this is this is a
transitionary period in which we're here
to help move forward
um but also what it does is uh at a I
think a deeper level if you're a
Believer right you're homebound as well
because this ain't your home either and
so we really try to like break that wall
of like well us and them right together
yeah but yeah it's really what it is
which is us and when there's Us in
different paths and different struggles
and different things but we're all
homebound that's good I'm trying to
remember that that normalizes like the
experience that normalizes you serving
that normalizes like the just the
community aspect of it all because if if
it's us and them we're always going to
be apprehensive even even though we're
there people sometimes serve but they
serve with suspicion or they serve with
they put their own parameters around
themselves so they can't fully Avail
themselves that's not what Christ did
you know so if if we're seeing it like
that as hey we're all together then I
think the service
um it just it's Monumental and a lot of
things can happen okay yeah all right so
two scenarios one
um
man why don't they just go to a shelter
why they have to be on the streets oh
man
good question at least okay so in
Orlando
all the shelters are full and they have
been full for a while permanent support
of housing is at capacity there is no
more permanent Supportive Housing and
rent has gone up for some people as much
as 600 700 800 a month
that's utilities
that's the cheapest thing yeah yeah so
so now with all of that at capacity
where are people gonna go there's
nowhere for them to go because what
happens is when you start to experience
homelessness the first thing you think
of oh shelter I need to find a shelter
and they call a shelter the shelter says
hey we're full so now the show hey there
might be some resources here you go
here's a page or whatever but but there
needs to be and that's why our vision is
that every metropolitan area in the U.S
has a has A Drop in Center for people
experiencing homelessness because
what every city needs a comprehensive
front door for people experiencing
homelessness when you're first
experiencing homelessness they need to
be able to go somewhere to say I don't
know what to do this is my first time I
don't know anything in the community
guide me coach me like like show me the
way you know because then we can go to
the shelters and have contacts at the
show hey you got room you got room for
this person you got room and if there
isn't then we say okay let's let's keep
going and sometimes unfortunately some
of our friends just have to just have to
be on the street and we just do what we
can to right to meet those basic needs
while they're there until until we can
find a solution for them and sleep in
front of the shelter yeah a lot of them
a lot of people yes hoping and waiting
to get in free space right yeah yeah
okay the second one is I don't want to
give them money they're just going to
buy drugs
you know it's funny
I was thinking about something when you
talked about the person who got the
haircut the touch and thinking about
that scenario you don't always have to
physically touch somebody you can have
touch points of Grace so fine you're
struggling with wanting to give them
money or not how you respond to them is
key too you know what you say how you
say it and if you don't want to give
them any funds maybe ask them okay well
what are you in need of like do you need
food do you need them whatever and I can
just go
um buy that for you with a card or
something because you don't want to go
against your conscience right but um you
still want to help this person so
getting to the need I think will allow
people to really you know help them and
find out what it what it is yeah exactly
and I think another another way too is
like if there's a place like salt in
your community saying hey look resources
you need money for food salt at the
property the salt operates on there's
three meals a day you know why don't you
go there and instead whatever money
you're gonna give maybe he's asking for
20 bucks donate it to an organization
yeah to make sure that they can continue
running I mean we've had we've been
hearing about organizations closing down
when work lack of funding because of
lack of funding and and there's an
explosive growth of of homelessness you
know in different areas and we had a
shelter explosive growth of homelessness
in Orlando it was a shelter that had
been there for over 10 years that's shut
down yeah it's now closed down it was a
Youth Shelter too 16 to 24 year olds now
those now those youth are aren't going
to be on the streets
um and you know what I'm saying like
it's it's yeah it's we like we we need
to you know so that's another thing if
you don't feel comfortable giving money
maybe referring to an organization and
then donating to that organization that
could be another another way to support
definitely because that's definitely a
topic right addiction the thing that
people go to
um because it's the most thing that's
like seen yes you know
um and it's interesting because we have
these conversations
um again Us and Them almost mindsets
like there's a distinction
um but I truly believe like if we were
to see ourselves
you know yeah the fact that we all are
addicts to something you know some of us
is validation some other success some of
us it may be whatever it is whatever it
is media media I mean for some of us
it's like you know there's there's and
then since it's oh I'm not partaking in
that yeah so that's the problem but it's
like no like we all have something that
again brings down just like the word
homebound the term is like no let's
bring it down and we're all facing
something yeah
um because the reality is addiction
it's this is the salary I was um talking
about this with a therapist it's just
like addiction is the reason why we turn
to it
is because it's reliable
like it's it's it's been stable yeah
even though it's not it's not right but
that's the illusion right I know it's
gonna make me feel this way so I turn to
it
um but it only makes you feel always
we're just a little bit I think the
what our I think role is is to show like
that Jesus is actually more reliable
than the addiction itself right you know
and that only comes through actually
sitting down and building relationships
well let's delve deeper into that
because there is that pastoral aspect
the ministry aspect to it so there's
this quote I'd like to read here it says
Christ's method alone it will give true
success in reaching the people the
Savior Jesus mingled with people as one
who desired their good he showed
sympathy for them minister to their
needs and won their confidence then he
invited them follow me so have you found
this to be effective in your line of
ministry like how receptive are people
to the gospel or actually before we even
get there like how receptive receptive
are they to Hope
as you're mingling with them in the
streets yeah I think people it's funny
I'm about to shout out there's another
organization that does similar to what
we're doing people just want to be hurt
I love you all um but that's that's the
fact of the matter is that people just
want to be heard so if the Savior
mingled with people is one who desire
their good
um you want to be seen you want to be
heard In This Moment In your experience
of what you're going through
um can I see you can I just stand next
to you there was a young guy he's
probably about 22 or something and he
was just he just started talking to me
about his his past a little bit before I
went into work and then he was just like
oh man I never thought about that but
I'm not really saying much I'm just
maybe asking him a question or two and
he's kind of saying so yeah he's like I
never thought about that oh and then he
starts crying and and it was just like
this moment of of him just knowing that
there's somebody that's just there with
me because he he realized that he has no
one not his parents because I was like
do you are your parents around because
when you're younger it's kind of like
where your parents are where this he's
like my dad can't do this all this type
of stuff and um so I want to desire your
good right now in that I want you to
know that I'm that I'm here for you and
that we're gonna try to support you in
in any way that we can and and you're
you're being heard literally in this
moment yeah but I think it's key in the
quote right it says Desiring they're
good right now like I'm Desiring my own
good man through you and what I'm doing
right yeah it made me feel good no but
it's like you know you're designing
their good and people will know
especially like if if you're living in a
state of survival like you know
constantly like you I think you really
gain this sense of like
ulterior motive no and this person is
genuine okay you know and just because
you're dealing with people so much you
begin to know how to read people but I
think that quote is extremely
true like I I think there's no better
way of saying yeah like that's the way
you would approach if you really want to
um
there's this quote it was like
um to impress people do you do it from a
distance but to impact people it happens
like close up yeah you know and I feel
like that's that's exactly what what
Jesus did right
um I like how uh the message says it in
first John chapter 1 verse 14 you know
in Jesus the word became flesh and moved
into the neighborhood
awesome moved into the neighborhood you
know um and it's it's there's there's
there's this
as uh something alongs may call it
incarnational Ministry where it's just
like you're doing Ministry by moving
into the neighborhood and living there
and being there and being in the
community and knowing the People by name
and knowing like okay like I remember
the first time I went to assault my
first uh you know time there first time
preaching everything I remember I
preached and it was like crickets like
nothing they were just looking at me and
I'm just like you know uh and I mean
Eric sat down we're like all right no no
we need to make sure that
part of the Pastoral work is service
right okay right so showers laundry like
everything that everyone does we do and
when I do right right and through that
process it was like about a month uh we
I was just there getting to know
people's names sitting down with them
next time I preach and now ever since
then when we speak
I know you by name right I know right
and then and they listen because they
see no no I see you care because I see
you fold my clothes I've seen you clean
my clothes right you know and then you
clean the toilet after I use this
exactly I mean because that's what
that's part of what they're doing like
like one we believe and and they're
they're so
salt believes that relationship is key
in helping to end homelessness yes I
mean even with addiction I I actually
heard this from you the opposite of
addiction isn't being sober it's
Community yeah you know so so being
having that support and having that that
community and and and that relationship
with people like that quote emphasizes
is is what is key in helping people to
find hope to realize hope is there in
Christ and and through you know him
using the organization and right and
like yeah so that that's that's what we
believe and and relationship and
relational aspect is built into every
process everything that we do as an
organization it's not a fast track right
right because people jump to the end oh
follow follow yeah without doing all
that other stuff and it's funny because
the young guy I was talking to when I
said something about God he's like I
don't hear about God like you know I'm
sorry it's just it's just so I'm so used
to it yeah and then at the end of the
conversation he was like well you know
okay
um maybe and I wasn't even trying to go
that route or but he's so used to maybe
a parent or two saying no I'm just God
just without the Desiring is good
without showing him sympathy without
winning his confidence without meeting
his needs without meeting his needs you
know so it's important we're so quick to
get people into the church and they may
not show up in the way that we would
want them to whether they smell they
don't have clean clothes or whatever so
why not meet that need so they build uh
their confidence in that yes I can show
up here because one they they not
they're not just going to judge me but
they're going to help me get to where I
feel like I need to be to be able to
mingle with other people
yeah there's a there's a story I wanna I
wanna share you probably won't share it
because this is a humble guy right here
but uh but it was a there was a client
that um that uh wanted to go to church
like a traditional you know more of a
traditional church or whatever and we do
church service for them on property but
you know you want to go to the building
and and uh I you might have been there
too I don't know but um but yeah so so
you know I I think the the client was a
little worried like I heard people gonna
look at me like you know is it and so
will will he wears a tie-dye shirt was
it tied that shirt yeah flip-flops and
he wears like some ripped up pants or
something like that shorts and he goes
to the church when he picks up when he
picks up the client he picks up the
client the client's like Oh I thought
they're gonna look at me but they're
gonna be looking at you you know but but
that but I believe that was a beautiful
that's a beautiful illustration of of
you know what it means to understand and
hear people and to be in relationship
with people you know and and that's
that's what I feel like you know uh
we're called to exemplify through this
through this ministry you know something
it's called Christ's method because he
did this you know you think of how he
treated the disciples he washed their
feet before saying hey go do this to
other people and I learned recently a
lot of The Parables they're not random
he was using them because it relate to
the people that he was talking to and in
order to relate you have to get to know
yes yep so the ones about you know the
farmers or the fishermen like it's
because he was around and mingled with
those people and he used those stories
or their experiences to link them to
Heavenly things right and so I find that
so beautiful so anything else in in this
topic because I want to Pivot to what
the government is doing about
homelessness
[Music]
it's a little interesting with the
government yeah especially depending on
what city I saw a video the other day so
San Diego which um by the grace of God
will be actually in San Diego with an
outpost by God's grace we call him salt
outside we start branches in different
cities and stuff like that awesome when
I just saw a video where the the mayor
how they're attacking homelessness is
different they're like hey you guys I
don't know why you guys are out here
kind of vibe so then they said hey okay
we're gonna take you we're gonna take
everybody and we're gonna open these
sites like up like these parking lots
and stuff we're gonna put you guys there
and if you don't want to go there
um you're gonna be arrested yeah you're
gonna get arrested okay so say parking
lot like it's like these areas that
um
they wouldn't call it that they wouldn't
call it that but it's like here's a
parking lot here's an open area that's
not being used and you're like left up
to yourself or no they're gonna close it
off for them okay for for this group of
people who are experiencing this and
also give them food and clothing I don't
know about that part
I don't know but you do got a place
so one thing that's crazy about and let
me just preface by saying the city of
Orlando has been doing a really great
job in figuring out how to handle
homelessness yeah they're genuinely like
trying to figure out how can we deal
with this how can we get ahead of this
you know um with San Diego San Diego has
four times more people experiencing
homelessness than Orlando so
and we're we're doing 70 showers a day
five days a week right we're doing about
50 loads of laundry five days a week
we're doing more showers and laundry
than the city of San Diego in in Orlando
just alone just with us and in San Diego
they're they're doing less of that and
they're actually uh reducing hours for
those Services yeah and they have four
times more people than us like it's like
the need is so greater there but the the
resources are being taken away and so so
some governments you know they're
they're genuinely trying to figure it
out other governments are just fed up
they're like I don't want to deal with
this anymore like let's you know hey go
over there right you know we don't want
to see you we don't want to you know
whatever you know what I mean like it's
it's crazy the contrast well let's let's
give some context so the Department of
Housing and Urban Development counted
around 582
000 Americans experiencing homelessness
in 2022 so last year that's about 18 per
100 000 people in the United States but
what's shocking is that number is only
ten thousand less than what was counted
10 years ago in 2013. wow so and of
course it's very difficult to have
accurate numbers because homeless people
are very transient yeah they don't have
a specific look you might think there's
a lot of people who you you would just
see them on the street and you wouldn't
know they're homeless yeah and so we see
a lot of people like that every day oh
man yes running this type of ministry I
assume that you're plugged into what the
government is doing or you're aware of
the government's limitations hence why
this Outreach even exists so and praise
God the number is decreasing but why so
slow
so let me say something about that
number it's okay that's interesting
degrees that number is is is is is done
through something called the point in
time count so it's it's they call it the
pit count for short so they do this in
every community in the U.S where they
literally take a day maybe maybe two
days they they grab volunteers right and
they count people experiencing
homelessness so they count everyone in
the shelters but then they count whoever
they see on the street they walk around
and try and so so if they don't see them
they're not counted so there's
limitations how many volunteers do you
have if you only have three volunteers
you're only going to count so many
people right and then also you're not
going out at night everyone's sleeping
in their cars you're not going to be
able to count that group either if you
don't know where the encampments are
you're not counting that could be there
exactly so that number I would I would
dare to say that that number is a small
fraction of 100 the number of people
actually experiencing homelessness now
that number
um the reason why it's not it's not
changing much I think is because
um you know some communities are
figuring it out and and they're they're
doing well and and helping the end
homelessness and other communities are
doing worse and I think you know I I
think that's kind of where that that
balance is but honestly right now I
think we're going to be seeing an
increase yeah definitely in the next
couple years the communities that are
doing well like what's what's the
barrier that's how it should be but
there's a lot of there's a lot of
politics involved too of course and so
yeah when politics get involved
um you know but they're like for example
there are certain groups that all they
want to hear is that someone got a job
they don't care if they got house they
don't care you know they just oh you're
getting them jobs great you know then
there's another group that doesn't care
about the job thing they just get them
housed you get them food or shopping
they're not working together and yeah so
there's so so they because there's a
group that says this is how happening
because they are not doing what they're
supposed to be doing there's another
group saying hey Society has failed them
let's let's help them so you have these
two groups and uh and and sometimes when
one voice is louder than the other it
affects everything and there's just so
many so many political uh things there
that uh affected a lot I think no I
don't think it's like you know
two out of the North sometimes for like
human nature or anything that's because
it's funny you were mentioning that like
somebody like oh they just care about
this and this kind of reminds me you
know
um you know pastoral so my mind
immediately goes to like spiritual
things or like this we're just like I
don't care what happened is he baptized
no no but like this studies within the
church yeah for sure yeah
they're taking too long we've been
helping him for a month like yeah come
on yeah what's going on what's going on
and that's that's something too we we
don't put timelines like I know a lot of
organizations like oh if they don't get
they don't get in six months if they're
not where they need to be then we're
getting someone else or whatever I mean
we work with people for two years two
and a half years yeah and and they've
relapsed several times during that time
they've they've gotten arrested during
that time it doesn't matter you know if
they want to come back and they really
want to make this work yeah we will
stick with them and there was there was
one woman man and it was two and a half
years she finally got into housing yes
yeah and they had worked with her yeah
she had relapse a few times had gotten
locked up but she kept coming back no I
want to do this I want to do this and
that's what's important yeah coming back
exactly oh the joy when she says yes oh
man so happy yeah yeah or even with our
friend Richie you know yeah man two
years uh imagine if we would just cut
the services yeah you know and then not
seen like the man's life completely
changed it was more than six months too
you know for his situation you know so
it's so that's one thing you know that's
part of our relationship you know when
it comes even in the Christian uh world
right like we shouldn't be having our
minds so fixed on baptism that we're
we're we're we're not focusing on the
relationship because at the end of the
because so many people in in the
homeless Services you know their focus
is housing okay great so oh yeah housing
housing okay we got them in the housing
great let's go on to the next person
okay housing okay next person but it
doesn't stop when they get housed yeah
relationship the relationship should
continue after their house and that's
what you saw in that news story earlier
with our friend Curtis he was housed but
we still have a relationship with him a
year after he was happy I'm sustain it
um you know because there needs to be
you know it's not it's not there's no
ulterior motive here we're just focused
on creating genuine relationships with
people like that quote said because
that's Christ that's how you have true
success right that's what the quote says
right recycled a form because you were
saying that the main reason uh at a root
is lack of support so you don't want to
get them to a place and then remove
support and then they get and they go
back and go right back yeah yeah I'm
reminded of what um I believe your wife
shared the concept of uh
um person over project right like these
aren't just people that are just
uh projects and we're trying to get
kudos for for this like like you said we
don't seek to gain anything but by the
grace of God yeah you will be with us
when he returns you know yeah yeah you
know so we don't we don't serve and and
just to piggyback on that a little bit
we don't we don't serve expecting that
they will uh that they will like they
might not have any indication that they
want their housing their homelessness to
end there might be nothing there but it
doesn't matter we'll serve you anyway
yeah you know and and we've seen it
where a woman was coming getting
services with us for eight months did
not say you know talk to us here and
there that had no indication of her
homelessness wanting to end nothing
getting Services showers you know
laundry whatever and then one day after
eight months he said I'm done I can't do
this anymore I I need help you know and
it was an addiction you know that she
shared with with um our spiritual care
team and then they got him over to case
management and she got this us a detox
facility then a sober house now she's
off the street no longer addicted but if
we would have stopped serving her oh she
doesn't want her homelessness she wants
to be homeless you know let's let's we
need to save the room for someone else
that's that's not that's not the way we
operate and I I don't think
any place should operate like that and
that's my opinion but yeah yeah
I visited England earlier this year and
shout out to the east Croydon church and
to the young man that I met who runs the
Instagram page it was very nice meeting
you I was in England for about a week
taking the train visiting different
cities in my time there I saw one
obvious homeless person because you're
saying that you like people you might
pass people and they might be homeless
and you don't know but obvious in the
sense that he was like they had a tent
in the sleeping bag and he was sitting
down one compare that to New York City
five minutes or just take the subway
you'll see at least a handful and I'm
not knocking New York I'm from New York
just putting that out there so out of
curiosity are you from New York BK yeah
so out of curiosity I looked up
How England was was handling their
homeless their homebound population and
so they have the local housing
authorities it's their legal statutory
duty to provide 24-hour advice to
homeless people or those who are at risk
of becoming homeless within 28 days
legally they have to give people
emergency housing while the authorities
look into their situation so I wondered
if there was an American equivalent to
that resource that we may not be aware
of awesome oh not you shaking your head
you say you're saying like what like the
closest police or the closest thing
that's come to mind when you mentioned
the passengers is in Seminole County
there's this uh police task force uh
called Coast
um and they it's literally like a police
unit and they're literally pulling all
resources to help those that are
experiencing homelessness in that county
um so they're like they don't need to go
to jail oh they need to just find
resources yeah
um we don't want to arrest them we want
them to get into housing right you know
and so they're that's probably the only
one in my radar yeah one county in the
United States well actually where
exactly is that is Seminole County
Seminole County it's uh it's a
rainforest Central Florida yeah Central
Florida so but that's good every County
yeah
not like that to that level though
[Music]
that would that would be great we we
experimented with a program like that um
to some degree using extended stay
hotels so we someone would be
experiencing homelessness they see a
case manager it depending on their
situation their eligibility will get
them into an Extended Stay uh which is
almost like a small apartment you know
and then our case managers actually had
an office in the Extended Stay we rented
a room that was their office and they
were focused on helping these 10 people
these 10 people's homelessness and we
gave them we gave them three months in
the Extended Stay it was with a grant so
there's certain parameters but it gave
us three months and and not I believe
nine out of the ten that they were
serving ended up getting into housing
yeah
um you know but that that was and then
we did one with pregnant mothers you
know that are experiencing homelessness
we experimented with that so so that I
mean we've we've tried it I think some
cities have experimented with the same
kind of concept would you say the
ambassadors is similar to that I mean
kind of like front lines it's just a
yeah so people that you know if
someone's homeless they'll help them out
yeah but it's not focused on
homelessness is anybody
it's anybody like it could be a citizen
that needs help putting something in
their car they'll see them and they'll
help them put in their car yeah I
thought it was but homelessness is
something yeah try it you were talking
about the the last time you were here
you mentioned Government funding is that
still the case with salt yes so because
it's like okay if they don't have have
something organized at least they're
supporting those who are doing it
privately yeah the the local government
in Central Florida has been a big
support to our operation it's probably a
good 30 of our Revenue comes from local
government okay
um 30 that's like close to a million and
you know for the organization so that's
that that's been good but um you know we
are trying to reduce that percentage we
we want to be able to create Revenue in
other areas and we we have been and that
percentage has been going down but
really no organ organization or
nonprofit should be getting more than 10
of their funding from from Grants you
know why do you say that um so the
reason is because there was a non-profit
recently so they're the Pioneers the
Godfathers of mobile shower trailers for
the homeless and um they they ended up
shutting down this year and it was it it
like shook like every every organization
out there that that has a mobile center
a shook them because that that was
everyone they looked up man like they
started it so they shut down and the
reason why they shut down was because of
budget most of their budget came from
Grants a grant didn't come through well
yeah that's it so so we we we are as an
organization are trying not you know
because you never know what if the
government shuts down what if they do
another government shutdown and then you
know we we can't get grants for six
months or whatever it is wow so so speed
still goes on yeah the need's still
there so so yeah but but I will say the
government local government in Central
Florida has been super supportive of
what we're doing and and I believe it's
because we so we have a data team we
have a data analyst a reporting analyst
uh data intake a software developer so
they we actually are very intentional
with looking at our data to help us uh
inform our decisions and our goals and
things like that so we found out from
August of 2020 to March of 2022 we were
involved in helping end homelessness for
over a thousand people and so those that
data is what's you know it's showing hey
you know this is working you know
something we're doing here is working
yeah and it's Christ's method you know
what I mean and we're we're we're you
know we're hoping that that continues to
glorify God and lift up Christ you know
enough the way that we serve yeah so
amazing well thank you will thank you
Gerard thank you thank you Eric for
being on the show you've shared such
valuable information if people have
ideas on how to get into Ministry they
may have questions for you maybe they
want a what did you call it a drop-in a
a salt outposts we're calling them yeah
saw outposts yeah they're bouncy in
their cities how can they get in touch
with you yeah so I would say go to
um
saltoutreach.org
um you could you could email me to Eric
salt outreach.org see at
saltoutreach.org all right and we're on
you know we're on social media and stuff
so Instagram is salt Outreach we will
have all of those links in the
description below thank you so much for
watching if you haven't subscribed yet
please do so like this video share it
out to those and specifically churches
who need this information to get
involved in this type of ministry
and if you'd like to get in contact with
little light Studios you can find a
bunch of information about our ministry
at
littlelightstudios.tv and if you're so
inclined to help us out financially you
can do so through that same website or
by going to patreon.com littlelife
Studios where you can get exclusive
content I actually have a question for
you guys after in the post show that
we're going to give to our donors but
thank you so much for watching please
keep assault Ministry in your prayers
little less Studios and your prayers and
we will see you guys next week on LED
live bye-bye bye-bye later we live a
fast life but do you have time for God
do you have five minutes
[Music]
hey YouTube what is humility
hey YouTube What is love
hey YouTube why does God allow suffering
because when you die
video Bible study answers your questions
in five minutes or less
hey YouTube how do I study the Bible
hey YouTube can God give forgiveness for
my sins do you have questions like this
then I highly encourage you to check out
the Channel video Bible studies I dare
you to spend five minutes with God it's
proven that people remember things that
they see more than what they hear
lightwear believes the best way to share
your witness is to wear your witness
flightware has all kinds of graphic tees
that are a great attention-grabbing way
to share the gospel so head on over to
lightwear.shop and check out all the
cool graphic tees what do you want
people to remember when they see you
[Music]
thank you
foreign